What if one side of the earth always
faced aside while the other side was
forever shrouded in darkness?
Just how hot would it be on the bright
side and how cold with the dark one get
what part of the planet would still be
able to sustain life and will this be the
eventual fate of the earth?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the
earth was tidally locked to the sun.
Ever wonder why we only
see one side of the moon.
That's because the moon is so close
to our planet that the side facing us
experiences a much stronger
gravitational pull to earth.
It takes the moon just as long to make
one rotation on its own axis as it does
to make a full orbit around the earth
that makes the moon tidally locked to our
planet. Imagine if the earth
became tidally locked to the sun.
How long would you have before the extreme
weather made the planet uninhabitable
as one of the earth sides started getting
all the sunlight while the other side
was thrown into a never ending night?
Everything on the planet would change from
weather patterns to water composition.
The immediate downside of tidal locking
is will the absence of a day and night
cycle ever stayed out in the sun to loan
to the point where you can feel your
skin burning?
Well,
this is what would be happening all day
and all night on the earth's bright side.
The Sun would be constantly cooking the
bright side until the temperature became
so high that no life would be able
to survive. How high are we talking?
Well, it depends on how close
we were to the sun. Most likely,
well above 100 degrees Celsius.
The boiling point of water,
such intense heat would vaporize the
water on the hottest spots of the planet.
Meanwhile,
the dark side of the earth
would experience temperatures
well below zero degrees
Celsius, turning all of its water
into ice. Even if the atmosphere,
it didn't freeze completely on that
frosty side, the cold air would sink low,
increasing atmospheric pressure because
the atmosphere on the other side would
be continuously exposed to light.
It would heat up and expand causing
atmospheric pressure to drop.
Significant differences in that Miss
Ferric pressure would lead to hellish
storms all over the planet.
You better hold onto something if
you don't want to get blown away.
We'd be fortunate not to lose
our atmosphere altogether
in such harsh conditions.
Without it,
we'd be long gone because our atmosphere
is one thing that could keep the planet
livable by distributing
the heat across the earth.
The only possible place for life on
earth surface would be in the twilights
strip of land between day and night,
but given that 71% of our
planet is covered in water,
it's not likely that there would be much
habitable land in that twilight zone
anyway.
Lucky for us,
there's no way the earth will become
tidally locked to the sun anytime soon.
We're far enough from the sun that its
gravitational pull doesn't latch on to
just one side, but the earth's
rotation is actually slowing down.
What if one day the earth stopped
rotating altogether? Well,
that's a question for another.
What if
stop rotating altogether? Well,
that's a question for another.
What if.